on passe à notre deuxième sujet alors il
est question là de la secrétaire d'état
marlène schiappa c'est une analogie
assez surprenante qu'elle a fait pour le
moins parce que pour elle et pour
résumer les partisans de la manif pour
tous et les islamistes partagent la même
homophobie dans une interview à
l'hebdomadaire valeurs actuelles elle
dit effectivement elle parle de
convergences idéologiques entre les deux
elle l'a répété ce matin persiste et
signe
ecoutez-la qui en france est opposée à
l'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle et bien à la fois des
mouvements identitaires et d'extrême
droite mais aussi des mouvements
intégristes religieux
donc oui je maintiens très fermement
qu'il ya une convergence idéologique
entre ces deux mouvements pour les
droits des femmes et contre les
personnes lgbt marin de viry votre
réaction à ces propos mignot s'est
plusieurs fois consternant mais je vais
me c'est vraiment plusieurs fois
constamment d'abord un ministre ou une
secrétaires d'état c'est pas là pour
lancer des polémiques c'est là pour
travailler sur ces dossiers premièrement
deuxièmement c'est pas là pour favoriser
la confusion intellectuelle c'est plutôt
là pour essayer d'être clair et précis
sur ce qu'on raconte
troisièmement sur le fond c'est absurde
c'est totalement absurde quand on
connaît la sociologie
quand on connaît les idées quand on
connaît les dirigeants etc
la manif pour tous et quand d'autre part
on associe enfin on associe ses
dirigeants cette sociologie et cetera
l'islamisme radical
ça n'a strictement aucun sens la
convergence idéologique n'existe pas
c'est vraiment comment dirais-je un
cerveau envahi une mauvaise
communication qui qui peut dire ça c'est
absolument consternants sur le plan
intégré sur le plan de aussi de
l'exercice enfin de ses responsabilités
gouvernementales
jean mathieu est ce que vous trouvez
quelque raison a expliqué le propos de
martin cap nord je pense que en fait les
deux shows je pense que dans laquelle il
y avait ces grandes manifestations
contre le mariage pour tous
c'est vrai qu'on y avait une majorité de
gens on peut dire catholique mais il y
avait aussi des autres représentants des
religions c'est vrai on a pu voir
d'autres de d'autres confessions
manifester contre le mariage homosexuel
après il est vrai que le terme
terrorisme islamiste et mariage pour
tous l'association d'état il ya un souci
après il est vrai que aujourd'hui il ya
une alliance malgré eux
aujourd'hui d'extrémistes contre contre
la culture homosexuelle en france c'est
sûr c'est certain mais de mélanger et
terrorisme islamiste mariage pour tous
je pense que l'ajustement c'est une
caricature une caricature de débat et
c'est impossible ensuite de critiquer
même si on est contre la manif pour tous
est impossible de les critiquer alors
qu'il au moment où ils ont été mélangés
avec des terreaux système marin de viry
nous disait c'est pas un ministre et
secrétaire d'état de tenir de tels
propos jamais un victor dans les
chapelles un peu ce rôle dans le
gouvernement
c'est le rôle d'un ministère qui n'a pas
demi qui n'a pas véritablement de
services donc elle parle
c'est le ministère de la parole mais en
revanche je souscris à ce que dit et
marin tout en ayant le ministère de la
parole ça veut pas dire qu'il faut dire
tout et n'importe quoi
là on est vraiment dans ce qu'on
pourrait appeler du confusionnisme et on
a presque même peine à expliquer enfin
est-ce qu'on doit vraiment justifié
qu'il ya une différence entre les jours
de la manif pour tous et les terroristes
islamistes
c'est presque affligeant j'aurais envie
de répondre par rapport à ce que disait
jeunes stuart mais il vous savez qui
plaide quand même pour la liberté
d'expression
mais qui dit à un moment il faut essayer
en effet ne pas criminaliser ou
diaboliser ou
par c'est toujours par le côté
judiciaire pour critiquer les autres
mais il ya un moment il faut opposer le
blâme à ce genre de propos voilà c'est
bête et il vient juste le blâme à lui
opposer sais pas si vous avez eu
l'occasion de lire la totalité de
l'interview qu'elle a donnée à valeurs
actuelles
parce qu'il ya d'autres points qui sont
pas inintéressantes
d'où le on parle à l'étonnement sur ce
dérapage a failli avoir l'or après
derrière moi je vous avoue que le départ
quand j'ai vu que voilà c'était aussi
dans n'existe à l'heure actuelle et ce
qu'il y'a pas un peu de provocation de
la part de l'ami de la secrétaire d'état
a aussi voilà c'est ça faire diversion
conversion politique c'est le b à ba ba
de la politique quand vous avez un
problème fait une diversion c'est pasqua
qu'ils savent très bien mais alors oui
mais voilà sur le timing a parce que là
je sais pas quand a été donné cette
interview on est généreux s'est pas
adressée pour répondre directement par
exemple la peña là parce qu'on n'avait
pas de chanter hier nous ça fait pas une
semaine qu'on se demande quand est ce
qu'on va sortir un port benalla on sait
que ça va être le mercredi et donc on va
faire une manchette dessus et donc il va
falloir d'épargné passé grésillement ça
se prépare ça se prépare
et puis franchement je veux dire alors
je me suis croyez pas jacques à cette
manoeuvre pour le nom nous a permis à
l'est d'alger autres sujets trouvé ce
matin ce sujet était en troisième
position pour le dédouaner thème du
débat aujourd'hui mentor deuxième on
aurait fait le débat deux peut-être
trois heures plus tard parce que la
polémique aurait en fait serait devenu
deuxième ça fait le buzz de dire qu'est
ce qui fait le buzz depuis 24 heures
c'est shia parfum à la remplacer edouard
philippe et ses critiques sur le sénat
c'est tout c'est comme ça après il ya
une chose qui est étonnant c'est qu'on
se souvient quand emmanuel macron
candidats février 2017 qui dit il ne
faut pas insulter les manifestants du me
contre le mariage gay et c'est ça qui
est assez étonnant c'est que là d'un
coup on ne sait plus justement ce que
pense ensuite emmanuel macron de cette
déclaration
qu'en pensent nos internautes on va le
découvrir alors la question twitter
marlène schiappa doit elle s'excuser
pour avoir approché la manif pour tous
et les terroristes islamistes
on disait s'excuser dans notre intitulé
parce que c'était une demande de la
manif pour tous en réaction aux propos
de la ministre
alors si vous êtes 76% à dire que oui
citoyens payeurs dié à marlène schiappa
adore faire le buzz c'est sa génération
monsieur babineau schiappa est beaucoup
trop présentes sur le plan médiatique
elle a une soif de notoriété et dany si
l'on signale des convergences n'est ce
pas honnête de mentionner aussi les
divergences
lesquels sont abyssales
je pense qu'il aurait été plus juste et
plus honnête intellectuellement limite
de faire une similitude du jusqu'au
boutisme
c'est effectivement la manif pour tous à
une forme à une forme au long du débat
sur le mariage de jusqu'au-boutisme on a
pu voir se demander bon ok la loi est
votée
pourquoi il continue l'amalgamme
effectivement est détestable sur la
finalité de la chose on peut pas
comparer un mouvement social qui voilà
qui manifestent après qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas d'accord moi je suis
plutôt pas d'accord avec eux mais ils
ont le droit de manifester
il n'y a pas de morts je veux dire cessé
de la libre pensée très bien dont acte
avec du terrorisme islamique qui
assassine vire des gens qui n'ont rien
demandé c'est de ce point de vue là hein
c'est plus mon ami effectivement c'est
plus qu'une maladresse c'est une faute
politique important alors on va voir
comment l'analyse alain finkielkraut le
philosophe il a réagi là-dessus et il
dénonce bien pensants de gauche c'est ce
qu'ils veulent
il aurait voulu que mes agresseurs ce
soit la manif pour tout ce qu' ils
soient à la fois contre l'avortement et
contre moi mais c'est complètement
dingue et je voudrais signaler rien pour
pour enfoncer le clou qu'aujourd'hui en
france des églises sont profanés d d d d
d d d d acacia oublie augmente et on
n'en parle pas et imaginer que si c'est
des écoles et des synagogues été
profanées tout le monde en parlerait or
c'est aussi grave et c'est donc mais
cette idée est complètement folle il a
réagi très vivement à woinic un côté pas
trop compris l'idée de la comparaison la
série des scellés sur la campagne oui on
va pas on va pas assister je pense que
là on est même jusqu'au bout et à
l'antisémitisme dont il a été victime
alors peut-être mais si on veut vraiment
rentrer dans une logique kazim odier
trop logique comme on dit en italie
peut-être que ça répondrait plus à la
rigueur aux problèmes qui se posent sur
ce plan c'est à dire sur la question de
l'antisémitisme ou indéniablement
peut-être que certains territoires et
lectorat de banlieue trouve qu'on en
fait peut-être un peu trop dans ce
combat contre l'antisémitisme et
peut-être faut-il enfin moi je ne
rentrerai pas manifester encore qu'on en
fait trop
personne aujourd'hui m'a dit vraiment on
en fait trop là bas parce que vous n'y
êtes pas officiellement bien non il n'ya
pas de fiscalité mais c'est indéniable
que gaia il ya peut-être ce genre de
considération mais de toute façon ne
rentrons pas dans ce genre de deux des
balles beaucoup trop à mon avis un sur
interprétatif je pense que c'est une
erreur ou une bêtise du confusionnisme
mentale points